[Music]
welcome to store corner 50 and we're so
delighted to have you here this is the
biggest story on so far or expecting
almost 500 people over the weekend the
stoic garden store on eggs into until
the CTR and we have I think approaching
5000 equal this year of doing stoic we
so I I hope you all enjoy and we're
looking forward to talking to you about
Scalia philosophy I am Peter from
stoicism Toronto Toronto screaming stoic
free hey this is my first time here at
Stoics
let's talk on I'm really excited to help
me pull out the defense of my ability
spade not to the fullest extent that I
can and hopefully everyone full of it
[Music]
it's really good to be back at stomach
on every year it gets bigger and bigger
chatting to build these communities just
a story every day
I'm a professor of professional practice
and entrepreneurship from the school of
education at University of Albany and
I'm is stoic
that's do it for comfort integrating
stoic system into my leadership courses
the graduate students educational leader
is administrators university presidents
and it's been completely absolutely
transformative but most of my experience
with Noah says he's really been on a
personal level in my classrooms this is
the first time I've come to an event
with people who really are deeply
committed and stoic so system so the
philosophy and I'm really excited to be
here and how people are doing everything
well it's always pays to be thankful the
Stony Creek and the stoy code I mean
this time and it's getting bigger and
bigger more international
such a variety of some people and you
meet interesting people it's amazing how
stoic people
let's hope they the even increase in
number over the last few years that we
are on the way to great success Thanks
I got to meet let's share my class with
my I actually have a bunch of between
two phosphors
usually you have this way people to wear
these things
we discovered at the border that their
passports expired was that insufficient
ID but outside of that things went
really well we think I had to export
some people to talks in between
different workshops and that was almost
more beneficial for me than them because
I got to see little snippets
what is great I feel like this this
year's a lot of personality and
it's generally the best thing was you
could hear it this year because the
acoustics were great in the room but
really I really enjoyed market cream the
keynote speaker she she really brought
home the substance of achieves that I
think that we all need to discuss
[Music]